[Music]
all right uh so welcome everybody uh my
name is Josh and today I'll be giving a
lecture on opening decision making so uh
to clarify exactly what that means that
I'm not going to be talking about any uh
Theory or any like broad ideas and any
specific opening or anything like this
my goal is to talk about the situation
when you don't know Theory or don't know
what moves to play or like don't even
know like maybe specifically the ideas
but just thinking about how you would
play in a position that occurs fairly
early on and the mindset you want to use
when you're surprised or don't know
exactly what is happening so we're going
to be jumping right in here with a
couple of games so the first game that
we're going to be looking at is actually
a game that I was shown by a student so
just a couple of days ago I had a lesson
with Julian prolako who works at this
very St Louis chess club and in this
game he was playing Black against Dalton
Perrine so both players are nms or I
believe Dalton is actually an FM and so
they're both around 2200 feet high so
we're gonna be looking at this game
so uh Julian goes for the Sicilian with
D6 and so uh Dalton decides to go for
this sideline surprisingly came very
early with move 5 F3
so the move F3 is not unheard of but of
course it's nowhere near as common as
the main move Knight C3 which is much
more common and much more natural so
here what we need to do as black we are
surprised in the opening is we need to
start thinking immediately right so
whenever our opponent makes a move that
we're not immediately familiar with it's
important to not just play on autopilot
it's important to take some time and
figure out what is going on so number
one whenever you see an unfamiliar move
and doesn't have to be in the opening
but just any move that you weren't
necessarily expecting you always need to
make sure you understand what is the
point of the move so the move F3 so if
black makes some generic development of
like E6
um white is not going to play Knight C3
here because if that was White's desire
uh White would have just simply played
Knight C3 on the previous move and Then
followed up with F3 so the idea behind
the move F3 can anyone tell me what that
might be
yeah very good and what is your name
okay Caleb yes
yeah I remember our game but not your
name so yeah okay so
um so so yes so the idea of F3 is to
prepare the move C4 so white wishes to
protect the E4 Pawn without obstructing
the C pawn and so if black plays a move
like E6 or G6 or such white will play C4
and white wants to play with this Roxy
bind setup so White's gonna be having a
lot of space here and controlling D5
it's not inherently like super terrible
for for black or anything like that but
is this a position that many black
players find to be uncomfortable so uh
in this case uh so the important next
thing to do is now that we understand
what F3 does we also need to understand
why
people don't play this all the time so
what I mean by that is like
so this position after Knight F6 has
occurred uh thousands upon thousands of
times probably in my guess would be
maybe an even in the hundreds of
thousands sort of order of magnitude so
and in this position probably 95 of the
time white plays move Knight C3 and I'm
sure that Julian being a pretty strong
player around 2200 v-day wasn't just
simply going to just uh just go into
this position knowing nothing about it
so of course Julian had some idea
against Knight C3 so then against F3
it's important to think about okay so
obviously not everyone plays F3 pretty
much everybody plays Knight to three so
why does everyone not play F3 so
generally speaking if your opponent
makes a sort of like offbeat move there
is a good chance that there is some
drawback to it because well first of all
most moves in chess are going to have
drawbacks no matter how good they are
but also just because like if the move
is offbeat usually it will be offbeat
for a reason for the most part people
are relatively Smart in the chess
community and they're not going to
continue doing something that is bad so
in the case of F3 so we need to think
about why do people prefer the move
Knight C3 over F3
so one immediate reaction is to think
that F3 is a move that covers the E4
Pawn very solidly but does not exert as
much influence over the center as a move
like Knight C3 would so there's actually
several ways for or pretty much one
immediate way for black to punish this
directly so
um because white is not having control
of D5 because there is no Knight on C3
black can actually uh
go for this Pawn structure with the
immediate E5
um and so so E5 is really good here
because uh in normally white would want
to have Knight on C3 so as to preserve
control of the D5 Square which has been
freshly weakened by Black's E5 advance
so uh in this case Additionally the
normal square that white would like to
place the Knight on when it is her
astrum D4 would be B5 so you can see
this as for example in the session cup
variation of the Sicilian after knight
f693 uh black wants the white normally
want to place the Knight on B5 in this
Pawn structure so the reason for this is
because the Knight on B5 is relatively
easy to reroute to the D5 Square whereas
uh B on B3 for example it would be much
more difficult
so
uh going back to the game so if we're
just looking at the case of F3 E5 so
Knight B5 here would be White's ideal
place for the Knight but unfortunately
white will find himself without time to
play the move C4 so because after A6 the
Knight is going to have to reroute to
the A3 score if white really wants to
play C4 and black has a couple of
options here but I think D5 makes a lot
of sense considering the Knight on A3 is
a very suspect
so white most likely would end up going
for Knight B3 and now we can see that
because white has refrained from playing
an early Knight C3 in this position
white actually does not really have
control of this D5 score at all and
indeed black can immediately simplify
the position with D5 most likely we're
going to see some sort of early Queen
trade and the position is going to be
very safe for black
additionally it's also possible for
black to play Bishop E6 simply allow
white to to implement his idea and then
just play normal chest which is also
possible and perfectly fine for black so
the key here is that uh by understanding
the drawback of the move F3 we can get
to the an understanding of what the best
move actually is so uh
Pandey in chat suggests uh E5 followed
by Knight takes E4 yeah unfortunately
this is a lot of uh of material I think
probably white should be fine after
moving the king to D2
yeah unfortunately that is a lot of
material but honestly not the worst idea
I've seen like it's definitely a typical
theme
um but yes so in the game uh Julian was
not thinking about this and so what
happened was that uh since Julian is
familiar with playing The Accelerated
Dragon a little bit he decided to Simply
transition into that and that's a really
common mistake that people make when
they're faced with an unfamiliar uh
opening setup
people often try to shift towards
something that is familiar and this is
not always so bad but it's really
important to not just automatically do
that since a lot of the time there's
going to be a problem with doing so so
if we uh just play a couple of moves
we'll see that we actually end up in a
relatively standard uh position so
thankfully for black nothing has gone
terribly wrong in transitioning back to
this sort of accelerated Dragon position
so all of these moves are fairly
standard a5a4 is really typical maneuver
for black since a lot of the counter
play for black is going to revolve
around weakening the C4 Pawn
so Castle is Queen A5 Rook B1 Bishop E6
all variable moves Bishop on E6 helps
black to attack the C4 Pawn in
conjunction with Rook fc8
say Rook C1 Rook C8 B3 takes takes
Knight D7 extremely typical uh Knight on
D7 influences the C5 and five squares
very effectively
so after Knight B5 now we have a point
where black has developed all of their
pieces to a more or less
to more or less just the most obvious
squares and now it is time for black to
construct a plant so there are several
plans available for black in this
position and here is a point where
definitely you would want to spend a lot
of clock time trying to figure this out
because again all of our PSR have been
deployed to the most obvious positions
and now we need to actually do make a
plan that does something
so there are several moves that make
sense
one of these plans is uh Queen B4 with
the idea of bringing the Rook into A2
and this is probably the most effective
plan due to the positioning of White's
pieces the move Bishop D2 is met by
Queen C5 check which is slightly
inconvenient for white perhaps at this
point white should strongly consider
repeating moves with Bishop E3 Queen B4
and so black is very likely going to be
able to get the Rook to A2 and there's
going to be a lot of counter play along
the second rank so Queen B4 is one plan
and probably the best another plan that
makes a lot of sense for black is to
play the move Knight E5 and eliminate
the strong nylon B5 with the move Bishop
D7 so this plan is makes a lot of sense
because if black is allowed to take on
B5 then the dark Square Bishop on G7 is
going to be extremely powerful and if
white ever elects to trade off the dark
Square Bishops then the imbalance with
the Black Knight versus the white light
scribbishop is going to be very
favorable for black so white would
probably end up retreating the Knight
and black can choose Knight C6 and
continue to trade pieces in any rate
black seems to have a fairly comfortable
position here
so instead Julian decided to go for
another plan with Knight C6 to control
the B4 square but the truth is that
white does not really want to play the
move before anyway since the move B4
would severely weakened the C pawn and
create a lot of problems for white so
again not the most effective plan uh
being used here
so after Knight C6 white plate King H1
which is a move that is generically very
useful since uh there are often various
tactics along this diagonal and so now
we can see why this plant is so
ineffective because in the case of
Knight before the most ideal move after
Bishop D2 the pin on the E1 to A5
diagonal is going to be extremely
unpleasant for black as there is no
obvious way to address the problem
so then here it's also very important
for black to think here about how about
how to play
um
so again blacks pieces have been
developed to pretty reasonable positions
uh nine on C6 is not optimal but we have
succeeded in our plan of placing 9 on C6
so now what I think makes the most sense
is to play a move like Queen d8 so this
move prepares Rook A2 and also prepares
Knight B4 since Bishop D2 is no longer
as effective now that it's not creating
a pin here
um and yeah so we can see that this is
pretty clearly this is a inferior
version of the earlier line with Queen
B4 where the Rook is coming to A2 right
away and Queen on V4 exerts a lot of
pressure into position but
um still nonetheless would be a pretty
effective way to go so
yeah probably Queen d8 is necessary here
unfortunately uh Julian didn't I think
he played a little bit too fast and
ended up committing a tactical mistake
with the move Queen before so uh move
Queen before
unfortunately the black queen is
entering the position which is not
inherently bad
but there are some tricks white has
available so Queen B4 prepares Rook A2
as we established before and again black
would be very happy to play Rook A2 as
The Rook uh creates a lot of pressure in
White's position
but because of the unorthodox
positioning of Black's Queen and
especially the fact that the Knight on
C6 is no longer on D7 and available to
control the C5 Square white has a really
interesting trick here to enact a sort
of Queen trap so
um yeah so the best move here is C5 so
the problem for black is that the uh
most obvious move D takes C5 will run
into Bishop D2 with a queen trap
it so happens that the position here
after Rook d8 allows black to more or
less Salvage the queen but the position
that results from it is very much not
acceptable for black so Knight takes B4
would simply drop the C5 Pawn probably
starting with Knight C7 is best an
average cakes before Knight C7 the
doubling of the e-pons means that black
should probably eventually lose the game
although there is some
chest left to be played but definitely
not what black wants to be doing
so in this case it is also very
important to make sure that you don't
lose your cool and just because we're
losing the D6 Pawn does not necessarily
mean that the game it should immediately
end so Julian plays with K2 which I
believe is the best move
so yeah we can see just how unfortunate
it is that this new Queen before was
played because uh now the D6 Pawn is
going to be exceptionally weak generally
speaking if white is able to play C5 and
capture on D6 in this Pawn structure
it's going to be quite unpleasant for
black
so we have Bishop C4
and uh
so here it would not be too great for
black to take on C4 as Pawn take C4
would open up the B file for the white
Rook
so
and unfortunately uh Julian here makes a
miscalculation
um and we are sort of beyond the scope
of the lecture but after D5 he takes D5
rook d8
and Bishop G5
yeah Julian makes a sort of
miscalculation here with Rook D7 and
after CLI 1 it appears that white is
going to win the game since after Queen
takes E1 Rook takes E1
we should have takes D5
unfortunately at the end there is a
knight C3 with a fork on the two Rooks
here and the rest of the game is not
particularly of instructional value so
what I want to bring to attention in
this game is the mindset which you would
use to make the proper choices uh pretty
early in the game so especially here in
particular I think this is a really good
moments to do some thinking and
hopefully by applying the mindset where
you think about your opponent's idea and
their uh and the drawbacks of their move
you can reach a sort of punishment of
the idea and so here this is one really
important moment and the next really
important moment would have been at this
position
where it's really important to make sure
that you take some time and think about
where you want your pieces to go and how
you want to implement a plan or
something like this
so I think this is a really good moment
where you need to spend some time to
think about how you want to get that set
up and here as well with the move
it's very important to at least consider
the move Bishop D7 as it's very natural
to want to make this trade
yeah and then from there in this
position this is more or less a tactical
misstep and queen d8 would also be a
more effective plan
okay so now we can move on to the next
game so uh
so in the in the game we just looked at
there were indeed some
positional mistakes that happened in the
opening but this game that I played
white I played like the probably
significantly worse than that which is
good because it's more instructional
this way so in this game was from the
Canadian open of Summer of last year I
was playing White against my good friend
the Canadian v-day Master uh guananteria
song
so the game starts with D4 so I know
that my friend here plays the benko a
lot so I just started decided to start
with Knight F3 so as to sort of
discourage that
unfortunately I did not realize that
black can still play B5 so here is a
moment where it's really important to
think about uh what exactly to do
because I've never seen this position I
had never seen this position before in
my entire life so
in this position white has a lot of
different options so clearly the idea of
Black's position is that in the case of
C4 this is very this we've actually sort
of transposed back to the Banco Gambit
and in this position I believe black can
choose between taking on C4 and playing
B4 with a sort of uh
uh benoni structure with the bishop
going to G7 and black should be
relatively fine in either case so pretty
quickly I decided I didn't really want
to play C4
and another move Knight C3
um
after B4 it seems like the Knight on C3
is going to have to go to a sub-optimal
location and so I also felt that black
would have a pretty comfortable position
here
so there are a lot of options here for
white
perhaps we can get some suggestions in
the audience or in the Stream chat
because there are a lot of different
ways that white can play here and they
have different ideas for the most part
I'm sorry what'd you say
uh and what is your name
Woody okay so Knight D2 is very natural
to prepare E4
um unfortunately we are actually
stopping the communication of our Queen
in D5 Pawn so it actually would be
hanging here
um but so yeah I did very briefly
consider an ibd2 because it's a very
natural move to try to play E4 but
unfortunately just doesn't really work
out too well in this position
um I would consider the 494 Bishop D5
the trading my econ for the bond I don't
really want to do that so so I would
strongly consider A4 and then after B4
trying to somehow occupy the C4 Square
okay I understand
um yeah the the immediate E4 here I had
judged to be bad because after Knight
takes E4 uh it is not possible to take
on B5 as Queen A5 check is I think
winning a piece right
um so yeah so funnily enough the
computer actually is relatively fine
with playing this position down the pawn
um since on Knight F6 it's going to take
on B5 uh when there's no such tactic and
a 96 Bishop for the Knight on D6 is very
bad for black but for me this is this is
this is very abstract it's it's not
clear to me at all why why I want to
make this uh exchange of my epon for the
black b-pawn so yeah it's definitely
interesting uh and A4 we're going to
talk more about A4 in a second here so
just hold tight gas fees official in the
chat suggests the moves E3 and Bishop G5
yeah I believe Bishop G5 is is probably
the the most like uh
I don't know if I should say natural
move but this is the most common move in
this position if I'm not mistaken and
indeed the idea is to capture on F6 and
build a center with E4 which makes a lot
of sense against blacks or the queen
side demonstration so in Bishop G5 uh
probably this is the what uh what would
most likely be figure uh what am I
trying to say but that the correct uh
mentality should lead you to because uh
I mean computer rates at E4 more highly
but this move is very difficult to
consider from a to consider very
seriously on a deeper level
and uh move E3 as possible but uh just
not really a very uh ambitious setup
here and indeed after Bishop A7 it felt
to me like I'm going to lose the D5 pawn
and in return for the B5 pawn and I just
wasn't really too thrilled about that
possibility
so in the game I thought okay well black
is clearly intending to play Bishop B7
and attack the D5 pawn and that's
another a big reason why Bishop G5 is so
sensible because after Bishop B7 now I
can simply capture on F6 and cause black
some double bonds it's not the end of
the world or anything but definitely a
little bit inconvenient for black
so yeah probably so I did consider
Bishop G5 and that's almost certainly
what I should have done and in the game
I did play A4 so basically I played A4
because uh I know that black does not
want to play Black does not want to take
an A4
um since now the pawns would be split up
in F9 C3 you can simply can continue
with E4 and have a very nice position
and uh if black now wants to play Bishop
B7 and make the trade of the D5 Pawn for
the B5 Pawn
well there's many different ways that
white could respond to this but probably
just taking on B5 is the best and Knight
takes D5 E4 seems pretty good for white
uh Knight C7 for example with a knight
C3 and everything is protected the B5
Pawn is actually very annoying for black
since Knight C6 is not going to be
possible
so I knew black was going to play B4 and
then I figured okay well here that means
that I can just play C4 and now my D5
Pawn is going to be protected
so now black doesn't really have any way
to win the D5 Pawn if black takes on C3
I'm not terribly worried I'd simply take
with the Knight and proceed with E4 and
we'd have a relatively typical benoni
Pawn structure
so black does the correct thing and
continues with G6
and in this position
um
uh it becomes very concrete very fast so
in this position after G6
um
what white should play is white should
realize that there is not going to be
really any chances for an advantage with
the queen side completely closed and
develop normally so there are a couple
of ways to do that in this position it's
really important that if black it's
really important to realize that if
black opens the center this is very
problematic for white since the queen
Side Pawn structure favors black in most
end games being the one who has more
space so what white should do is white
should play a move that just should
develop in such a way that discourages
black from opening the center with the
move E6 so the best move here is G3
um
and in playing G3 with the bishop on G2
uh black will very frequently have
problems on the long diagonal after E60
takes E6 so
um I mean to be honest I'm not thrilled
about White's position or anything I
find that most of White's pieces are not
really doing much in particular the
Knight on B1 has to go to D2 which is
from which is a square from from which
it doesn't uh affect the game too much
so I wasn't really too happy about this
so I decided to play it more ambitiously
um yeah it's kind of sad that from this
Pawn structure we are already trying to
equalize as white but I played B3 which
is a move that feels very natural but if
we look at the game we're going to see
that tactically this move just doesn't
really work out it's really important
for white to get castled before the
Center opens up
so after Bishop G7 Bishop B2
so here I was already feeling very
uncomfortable about my position so in
this position we should think about what
black should do so
um
there's a couple of typical moves the
main moves the main move that black
should be considering is the castling
short which is indeed the strongest move
but the reason that we're talking about
it today is because black did not play
this move so the key idea here for black
is that castling short is not the
specifically important move but rather
the black does not have to play D6 which
is what happened in the game so after
castles Knight D2 black can actually
save time here and open the center
immediately which is really important
thing to do because White's King is very
far from being castled and indeed after
E6 there is a huge amount of trouble for
white trying to maintain the pawn
structure so
uh in this position if white wishes to
play E4 then after he takes D5 white has
a lot of trouble here with maintaining
the center so for example C takes D5
rookie 8 results in a double attack on
the E4 and D5 pawns surprisingly and
white is in a lot of trouble so perhaps
white would have to do e takes D5 but
then after Rook E8 Bishop E2
there are a couple of options for black
I believe I even thought Knight takes D5
was possible with some weird tactics
like this and overall I just wasn't
really too excited about playing this
position
um either way the opening of the e-file
is definitely not what white wants to be
doing and even if black were to continue
with something like D6
um yeah definitely not uh really excited
about this I don't really know what
where I should put any of my pieces and
uh yeah generally speaking looks like
Black's gonna be doing pretty well here
perhaps Knight takes D5 is actually
possible here since Bishop takes G7
Knight F4 is now more effective with the
E5 Square covered
so yeah I knew that I didn't really want
to be opening up the center so in the
case of so if this had happened in the
game I would probably have to make some
really awkward move
um
D6 makes sense to keep the center closed
but just because of the specifics of
this position it can't really work out
after Bishop B7 it's gonna be very
difficult for white to protect the D6
Pawn in the long run
so in the game my opponent played a very
lazy move uh D6 and I say this is a lazy
move because uh this move is just sort
of played automatically because well and
he confided in this to be after the game
as well he said more or less he said uh
well this is just what you do right you
just play D6 in the spawn structure but
in this case it's actually not necessary
and you can already start punishing
White's very slow development scheme
especially with the loose Bishop on B2
so anyway so we have 92 castles
and then uh so in this position white
still should play G3 and again try not
to do too much in the center with the
King on E1
um I wasn't really too happy with my
position when I was thinking about this
I couldn't really think of a plan for
white but at the same time it's also a
little bit difficult for black to play
since both Central upon advances for
black with D5 and E5 will create a lot
of weaknesses so most likely white
should be more or less equalizing here
although that's not really what you want
to hear when you have the white pieces
against the low rated player
so I decided to continue playing very
ambitiously for this reason and I
decided to start with E4
so after E4
and there's another position where my
opponent decided to play lazily so in
this position
um so the general plan for black is
going to be involving E6 of course at
some point in order to again as we were
talking about create some pressure down
the uh
you file so the question is should black
play E6 right now or perhaps do
something else
wow time is flying by
um so okay yeah so this is actually a
really interesting position because
against virtually any move other than E4
uh black should probably just play E6
um gas free gas fees officials suggest
Bishop G4 which makes a lot of sense but
uh black does have a better way to start
remember that white doesn't really have
a way to prevent Bishop G4 in the long
run so it's more important to solve the
Central Pawn structure first so against
any move other than E4 probably black
should just play E6 but because white
has played E4 uh black has a way to sort
of make a double attack here uh believe
it or not
so uh
in this position black is surprisingly
close to being able to take an E4 as
after Bishop takes G7 Knight takes D2 oh
it's very unfortunate for black that
white can take an f8 without which this
would be fine for black but okay
obviously black does not want to go up
the exchange for no reason
so the key for black is to start with
the move rookie age so the key here is
that not only is black threatening to
move E6 so uh
so if white plays a move like Queen C2
then E6 is very uncomfortable for white
with the opening of the e-file
but also after a move like Bishop E2 or
Bishop D3 in this case it's very
possible for black to take an E4 uh
right okay against Bishop E2 you you
take an E4 and Bishop takes G7 Knight
takes D2 results in an extra Pawn for
black it might not be that bad in the
end because but white does have a
powerful dark script Bishop but you know
black is winning a pawn for very little
and
um and in the case of Bishop D3 I saw
that black is now able to take on D5 and
after Bishop takes G7 though this really
nice intermediate move here in Knight F4
both Bishops are hanging and so I will
not be able to save both so in the case
of rookie 8 most likely in the game I
would have played Queen Z2 or something
but it's definitely not a pleasant
situation for white probably long
castling is forced and I doubt I would
survive for her too long
so um and of course artificial YouTube
but I can simply play E6 as well since
the white Bishop is not reaching the
quote-unquote optimal D3 Square to
protect E4
so rookie 8 would be a slightly more
accurate move order for black to execute
this E6 plan my friend ended up going
for E6 immediately which is a weaker
implementation
so now this is a really important
juncture for white so
um
for example I thought about a couple of
different moves here so the first move I
consider with Bishop D3 because well I
mean Bishop on D3 protects the E4 Pawn
but the line I calculated was after ed5
cd5 and Rook E8 I thought I was going to
be having a lot of trouble here since
again not only is black threatening
Knight takes D5 exploiting the pin along
the e-file but there's also a lot of
discovered attacks based on the long
diagonal such as in this position Knight
takes E4 and Knight takes D2 and black
succeeded in winning a pawn and I
definitely wouldn't want to do that so
that's why I didn't end up going for a
bishop D3
but I also saw that in the case of
Bishop E2 rookie 8. this is still very
annoying for me in the long run blacks
should be able to take and play Bishop
F5 after Knight E4 I will eventually end
up in an end game where the light screw
Bishop will have to face a knight and
that is something that I'm absolutely
certain I do not want to play Given that
the light Square Bishop just is
completely held back by all the pawns
and any end game resulting in such is
going to be if not losing at the very
least extremely unpleasant for white
so
the game I decided that okay well I
don't really like either of these
options so I'm going to transform the
pawn structure and so I made a very poor
choice to take an E6
um
so what white actually should do is that
the important thing here for White and
the thing that I want to get across with
the audience today is that at this point
it's really important to adopt the
correct mindset and that at this point
as white
you should just understand more or less
that uh that there's not going to be any
sort of Advantage here so I should just
stop thinking about that and just forget
about it and try to equalize and indeed
uh White should play Bishop D3 and in
this position take an F6
um
so this boot I think is really insane to
consider like I didn't really consider
this move very seriously because it just
looks stupid well okay like you know
like black is taking over the dark
scores and such
um but the truth is that here uh the
most likely situation is that black will
eventually Play Bishop G4 and maneuver
Knight to E5 and at the end of the day
we're likely to reach an opposite color
Bishop end game which should be okay for
white and this is the most effective way
for white play I mean it's very sad
because white doesn't really have any
winning chances here but white is able
to Castle and eventually try to maneuver
The Rook to E2 and white should be able
to draw after some solid defense so not
optimal but at this point this is
already the point beyond the point where
white should be thinking of having an
advantage and I think that's my key
mistake in this game
um where I was just thinking
I was just playing a little bit too
ambitiously because I know it's my
friend I know he's low rated than me and
so I ended up making some pretty bad
moves that should have cost me the game
so after d takes E6 so I had already
seen in the game that I don't really
like my position after either capture
but okay at least I'm not losing a pawn
to any discovered attack or anything
like this
so in this position
um this is a this is a position where
black can consider a few things so of
course black has two candidate moves
Bishop takes E6 and F takes E6 both are
very good in the game I was actually
most afraid of Bishop takes E6 because I
thought that uh black has a very simple
plan here so for example
um
what I figured was that eventually we'd
have a position where uh black is going
to trade a bunch of minor pieces and
eventually go for a queen of 6 and 95
and we would end up in a situation where
black is going to be having a knight on
D4 against a bishop on D3 and yeah
that's that's definitely not an ideal
situation uh I believe this bishop takes
E6 with this idea in mind should be
around -1 and in the game I thought that
if this happened I should probably just
lose because I felt that in a practical
game it's almost impossible to go wrong
with black and definitely wasn't really
feeling comfortable about what was
happening so far
but the move that my friend played in
the game f takes E6 actually turns out
to be even stronger so it turns out that
I realized that if black is allowed to
play the move E5 at any point
um then my position feels more or less
lost I don't really have any plan uh
because I so prematurely locked up the
queen side I'm definitely not going to
be able to play F4 at any point and so
black just is going to be able to take
over the D4 square and look for Bishop
B7 perhaps not H5 Knight F4 and yeah I
just I just felt like this this position
was not acceptable and indeed it's not
it's around -2 or so so
on this position I think I did the
correct thing and uh
and decided to go for some
uh things that may or may not be dubious
but at this point I know that if I just
play quietly I'm going to end up in a
losing position relatively quickly so
here I decided to just simply play E5 so
this is a very drastic measure of
this is a very drastic measure when it
comes to uh
when it comes to preventing E5 but in
this position it is definitely warranted
so and then this position as black it is
your goal to try to figure out how to
deal with this situation so there are a
few options here
so the main candidate moves for black
are D takes E5 which I saw and Knight G4
which was played in the game
so in this position after d takes E5 it
turns out that white can't really
effectively take on E5
um so I saw that Bishop takes E5 Knight
C6 extremely uncomfortable for me so
after Bishop B2 but I can do a bunch of
things here but E5 I think is very
strong and once the pawn comes to E4
white should not be able to survive for
too much longer
and in the case of Knight takes E5 then
black can make use of the pins with
Knight ft7 Knight H5 is also very strong
because bringing the Knight to F4 is a
great achievement for black in this
position and Bishop moves can be met by
Queen G5 or things like this
so uh yeah more or less white is not
really able to take back to E5 so the
way I figure white should probably just
lose as my as my guess at the at the end
of the day which is unfortunate but you
know that's how it is
the problem here is after Knight takes
E5 not only can black move the Knight
around and achieve a great position but
also black just makes a normal move I
can't really develop my bishop and
prepare castling so there's just not
really any way for uh for white to
reasonably play the game and
therefore uh this position is pretty
winning for black
but instead my friend played Knight G4
which is very tempting because it
creates a lot of strong threats
so
um in this position after Knight G4 it's
really important for white that okay so
there's no way to protect E5 in the long
run for example at Queen E2 uh just
Knight C6 is possible and the E5 Pawn is
going to be falling soon
so it's really important here to try to
solve the situation tactically and
indeed Knight E4 mixes up the position
considerably
so now we're a little bit past the uh
opening stage more or less despite it
being moved 12.
um but in this case the situation
remains extremely difficult for both
sides to play
so uh remove my friend played which I
actually thought was a very natural move
the move Knight C6
um
actually mostly discards the advantage
it's really important for black to
understand in this position that that
there is a more or less winning attack
present and therefore black should
continue with the move Bishop B7 and try
to maximize the pressure that is being
created
the problem with move Knight C6 that
allows black white to trade the Queens a
little bit too easily and that is the
problem with this move but after Bishop
B7 so what I intended to play was Knight
takes D6 but after Vision takes F3 takes
Knight takes E5 I'd already seen first
seen this in-game that this is pretty
much losing and I would more or less
expect to be resigning soon so now my
best uh showcase this game it would have
been pretty unfortunate if that ended up
happening uh it turns out that there is
actually a tactic which I just happen to
have just by pure luck with Queen takes
D6
since Bishop takes E4 uh Queen takes E6
and queen takes G4 allows white to
recover the lost material
um but in this position the queen trade
is a little bit more favorable as the F
pawns for white are doubled and
therefore almost certainly going to be
lost and in this ending with an extra
Pawn black has a pretty good advantage
so Bishop E7 is more appropriate here
for black as the very important to
strike quickly
so the game after Knight C6 takes takes
takes
um
yeah in this position now it is possible
to say that uh Black's advantage in this
end game is pretty small for the most
part
um
so uh
the the basic problem for black is that
white has fairly active pieces now and
there's no inherent problem with White's
Pawn structure or anything like that so
in the end games black May potentially
have problems with C5 or E6
so um in this position uh
I had already
thought that the worst is probably over
and at this point I decided to resume my
strategy of playing for the win so I
thought Rook D1 was a possible move but
I didn't really want to play this end
game as black is going to install the
bishop on D4 and I was pretty sure that
I was not going to win the game
um
so the game I played the move Bishop E2
so now in the case of Knight F3 I can or
Knight D3 rather it's probably better
then we would simply reach this position
and most likely I would probably have
offered a draw relatively soon as in my
view it seems like most likely opposite
they call it Bishops are going to happen
at some point
but it turns out that black actually has
these slightly more difficult position
as uh
as there are some difficulties with uh
developing the pieces for example Bishop
D7 uh Bishop E4 is a bit annoying for
black
so black ended up playing another uh
lazy move here with Bishop D7
um although the position is actually a
little bit strange for black already for
the record stock for schleich's new Rook
B8 which I cannot explain at all so
um so yeah Bishop D7 but this move turns
out to be lazy because uh after Rook D1
the idea of 93 is no longer feasible so
um
as or I shouldn't say no longer feasible
but no longer as effective because now
Bishop E4 is going to be possible the
most obvious move for black and Rook d8
will allow Knight B7 so
um black may have to play Rook B8 and
now uh I thought Knight B7 was possible
um with a double attack on the C5 and D7
Bishop
so Rook D1 would have been much stronger
but instead I was really excited to
Castle because well I just thought that
uh well you know I haven't been able to
Castle for so long so I was really
excited to Castle but indeed it is a
lazy move to do that and is important to
consider it Rook D1 so and if black does
not do that then castling is going to be
a lot more effective here and white is
actually going to be able to pretty
shortly look to drive out the Knight on
E5 and obtain a pretty normal position I
believe white is even slightly better
than that end game perhaps
so after castles then my friend here
plays the excellent move Knight C6
so Bishop takes G7 King takes G7 the
idea for black is the knight move Knight
D4 which is pretty much not Unstoppable
by white
so
um in this position I decided to uh try
Dr try to exchange my Bishop for the
Black Knight
so uh
in this position like apparently the
best move is is Bishop D1 which uh I was
definitely not really excited to play of
course I saw it was possible but after
94. apparently white should play F4 and
there are some concrete considerations
that make it so that this position is
acceptable uh so for example uh White
isn't tending Knight B5 so in the case
of Bishop C6 then Knight B5 is possible
and uh just hoping to exchange the
strong nylon D4 and if black tries to
prevent this with A6 and after Knight E4
it turns out the Knight is very
difficult to drive away from E4 without
hanging the C5 Pawn
so yeah Bishop D1 would have been more
appropriate but I decided that I was
going to keep playing ambitiously with
Bishop F3
so uh playing Bishop F3 I had already
anticipated that my opponent was not
going to let me trade my Bishop for the
Knight as that position is going to be
very pleasant for white with the Knight
on D6 and pretty soon double Brooks on
the D file so I'd already understood
that black was planning to sacrifice The
Exchange on F3 and play Knight D4
so uh in this case the double attack on
the pawns on F3 and G3 is very serious
um but I had foreseen that the move 94
was possible with playing with the
pressure on C5 being annoying for black
so uh yeah again we are fairly past the
extent of the opening but there are a
couple of moves I believe are
instructional that have yet to be seen
so for example uh an end game that we
had both misjudged was results after the
move Knight takes B3 uh Rook D1 Bishop
takes A4 so I thought that after Rook D6
I would have really good counter play
since uh the E6 Pawn is hanging and
black chooses to defend it which is
already fairly difficult the bordering
on Impossible then after E5 the move
Rook A6 is going to be possible
and after some bishop move then Rook B1
we'll first black two give up the C5
Pawn
um
but uh the computer says that black can
just give everything and try to promote
on the queen side and in the long run
it's almost impossible for white to stop
it which is
a little bit amazing to me but yeah
apparently black should just give up
everything here and continue pushing the
Pawns so this would have been the
strongest continuation
um I'd also thought that Rook C8 was was
very possible here as after Rook fd1 E5
Rook D3 so here I would have been like
pretty much fine with this in fact I was
going to continue playing for the win
here
um but uh then pretty soon after I was
thinking about this I realized that I
just don't have a plan at all this
Knight on D4 is pretty much unassailable
and therefore I won't be able to do much
to get it out of there and therefore
it's very difficult to make progress
especially with my weak King Side Pawn
structure
but uh my friend ended up getting a
little bit too greedy and decided to win
back the exchange with Bishop C6
and after Knight takes D5 so it's true
the black wins back the exchange but
unfortunately the Knight on D4 was
definitely a much more important piece
than the white Rooks and uh in this
position uh White should have some small
Advantage as it unites actually superior
to the light Square Bishop here and
eventually I managed to win this end
game after various twists and turns so
yeah hopefully that should be a good
example of you could think of it as how
not to play for both sides
goes to show that even in relatively
decent level games there are lots of
mistakes from both sides and all the
time
so yeah I just wanted to go over a lot
of the key choices here
um like A4 and pretty much every move
that results after this is uh bad from
both sides
um yeah Bishop this B3 move is not good
because it doesn't really meet the
demands of the position where I need to
keep the center closed
um and yeah this E4 move also has the
same problem with uh black lagging
behind by playing D6 very early
uh yeah here this is just a lack of a
calculation I think that probably my
friend just didn't really calculate
anything and just played E6 because it
looks very normal but yeah rookie a
turns out to be more precise
and D takes E6 is just completely
horrible and I should lose but some
Miracles happened and somehow I was able
to pull the full point out of this
okay so I think we have time to do the
next example It's relatively short
compared to these so all right so this
is actually a game from later on in the
same tournament and in this game I am
playing Black against uh the Canadian
um wgm Miami Jade Ula so we're looking
at um
a king's Indian here which I had
prepared and expected so um
here I really like the movie Queen A5 so
the idea behind this move Queen A5 is
that uh so first of all the line Knight
C6 which is the most common move uh
after a queen D2 and queen A5 this has
been considered for a very long time to
be a good line for black so therefore
people don't really play into this
anymore people play D5 after which
there's a ton of theory that goes on
um but I really like to move Queen A5
because first of all the most obvious
move for white is probably Queen D2 but
after Knight C6 we transpose back to
that line which is considered to be good
for black
and um
in the case of D5 which is another
possible move now black can get a sort
of Banco Gambit with B5 and A6 and this
is a very good benko as the white
Knights do not coordinate with each
other very well on E2 and C3
so the other critical response for white
is the move Knight C1
and after receipt takes D4
Knight B3 to try to recapture on D4 with
Knight
so this is a really interesting position
because after the move Queen B6 which is
a very strange looking move
uh turns out that white has some trouble
recapturing on D4 so inspiration if
white takes on D4 with the bishop then
after Queen d8
if she two Knight C6 and Bishop E3 uh
believe it or not this is actually an
accelerated dragon with a white having
an extra Tempo but white has used the
extra Tempo to play Knight B3 so which
is not an ideal move uh in fact uh I
think we have some time so I'll actually
show what that would more or less look
like
sorry uh so C4 Bishop G7 Bishop E3 so
this would be like pretty normal stuff
so in this position
um
you could so if we compare this position
with this position we see that uh white
pretty much has a
has the position after Bishop E2 with um
with the Knight on B3 so if we compare
this position with this position again
white has an extra Tempo in this case
but has used it to move the Knight to a
worse Square so this is considered to be
a very good version of an accelerated
dragon pawn structure
so that's the idea in case that Bishop
takes D4 and on Queen takes D4 uh black
is able to sacrifice the pawn here and
obtain really interesting compensation
in this end game in the long run it's
very difficult for white to hold on to
the C4 Pawn mostly because the nylon V3
is not doing a great job so this is just
the theoretical idea so far but the
reason I want to talk about that is
because I had previously prepared for
the moves Bishop takes D4 and queen
takes D4 because I did not even think
that this move Knight takes D4 was
possible
so here this is a point where again it's
really important to think about uh the
to go through our process where we
understand why our opponent is making
this move so uh
so I'd known that I'd studied this
position before and I knew that I didn't
consider an IX D4 because it's not
considered to be a good move it's not
shown by the computer it's not played in
human games so clearly there is some
reason why people don't play it and I
just need to figure out what so my first
instinct was okay well what happens if I
take on B2 because that just seems the
most obvious right and uh to be honest I
literally thought for like five minutes
and I don't know why it took me so long
to see that after Knight A4 the queen is
going to be trapped uh in a sad way so
show D2 Queen A3 and Knight B5 traps the
queen on A3 so that would definitely not
be acceptable
so then I started thinking about a
certain position so in this position
there aren't really too many other moves
for black to consider and so the other
move I was considering was Knight C6 so
it looks very odd but the pressure but
the tension along the A7 G1 diagonal is
actually pretty annoying for white so
again if we compare to accelerated
Dragon so this is a really good strategy
where you compare to other openings that
see what has been changed
um
if we look at this position after D6 F3
we would have the position after Queen
B6 but black would have also castled is
the exact position in the game if we if
we look at this case
um and this is only possible because
white has wasted so much time with the
Knight so that is why Knight takes D4 is
not so good because after Knight C6
Queen B6 is not a normal move in the
accelerated Dragon but this extra tempo
for black does make it actually possible
so in this position is now White's turn
to make the decision here
so in the case of the move Knight F5
which would be decisive pretty much if
black had not castled
um now after Queen takes B2 so I saw
that after Knight A4 Queen E5 black can
get the white is able to pick up the
bishop on G7 but the extra Pawn for
black is pretty good and indeed there's
actually a fun plan here so I'd seen
that that this position is probably good
for black but I had already thought that
maybe white has some compensation in the
long run as the uh lost the dark Square
Bishop is very unpleasant for me but
turns out there's this nice Pine with D5
and black is able to simplify the
position due to a weakness on E3
so um and if white plays a move like
Bishop E2 black is able to execute a
classic idea with the queen on V6 uh
they discovered attack Knight G4 so
after F takes G4 Knight takes D4 the B2
Pawn is hanging so Knight D5 is not able
to dislodge this on account of Queen
takes B2 and so therefore black is going
to have an excellent position with a
beautiful Pawn structure compared to
White
and the Knight on D4 is just absolutely
perfect here
so now it's White's job to figure out
what to do about this so the main threat
for black is going to be 924 so the most
important the first move for white to
consider is the move Queen D2 which
actually did end up happening in the
game
uh the strongest move in the position is
actually Rook B1 since in this case
after Knight G4 takes 95 there is no
Queen takes B2 available and therefore
black is going to be pushed off the D4
Knight and lose the game so that is
definitely not an option for black uh
I'd already seen that after Knight takes
D4 and I just moved the queen somewhere
more or less this position would be
pretty good for black
um The Rook on B1 is not an optimal move
and I will continue with pretty standard
accelerated Dragon ideas
but the move Queen D2 is a move that is
very natural and would probably be the
preferred move if
um if it worked tactically so Knight G4
in this case not effective since Knight
D5 as a really powerful in-between move
would end up winning something here
so
um
so here was the moment where uh
unfortunately Queen D2 does fail to a
tactical issue and uh again this is uh
or I shouldn't say again but uh yeah
unfortunately the calculation from White
is not optimal here as after Knight
takes D4 this is a pretty unorthodox
tactic but in this position you really
should be spending a lot of time as
white to try to figure this out so
definitely findable but yeah really
unorthodox tactic with Knight takes D4
and the obvious move Bishop takes D4
loses tonight takes E4 with a really
bizarre discovered attack here so of
course taking the Knight would lose the
bishop and Bishop takes D6 Knight takes
D2
yeah sadly you cannot capture the piece
and Retreat your bishop and it is
unfortunately not trapped as I can
capture on F1 with a winning position
here
so in the game white took on D4 and
ended up dropping the B2 Pawn which
resulted in a loss I actually played
like really badly this game and I
developed a super winning position and
eventually blundered my extra Pawn in it
and uh I I won the game anyway uh due to
some luck but uh but yeah definitely not
a great game but the point was I wanted
to discuss the sort of thought process
here starting with uh when I was
surprised in the opening by the move
Knight takes D4 and here I was able to
think about it compare it with knowledge
that I already have and use that
knowledge as well as my calculation to
build what I thought was the best move
um and indeed I ended up playing pretty
well here and uh so happens that it uh
is the correct punishment of White's
idea
okay
um I think that's a good stopping point
for today uh thank you so much for
tuning in and I hope that this uh
material is able to be applied to your
own games in the future thank you so
much
[Music]